the name of Jesus Christ most merciful
hallelujah hallelujah amen it was not
love at first sight me in New Haven when
I was moving here and especially in the
first weeks many many people pointed out
the New Haven has a lot of problems big
problems and they were sure to warn me
about them over and over again don't get
onto i-95 you will be stuck there
forever don't go to the woods bad things
happen there don't walk around on the
streets of New Haven they're scary I
heard over and over again that New Haven
was one big problem I was even told not
to go to this grocery store because it's
close by but to drive further out to the
suburbs where it's safer where there's
more distance how to navigate this scary
scary City was the advice I was given by
very well-meaning people yes safety is
so important it is a priority of Yale it
should be a priority for each of us and
yet these warnings I think were more
about just calling for three to walk
this was more about us and then
underneath some of these very practical
warnings was a sense that if we could
have a sense of us Yale within the
fortress walls that the them the scary
new haven out there would somehow be
kept at a distance and for a while us
and them was a place I was comfortable
being Jesus son of David have mercy on
me the cry came from the roadside as the
large crowd was making their way out of
Jericho Jesus son of David have mercy on
me the crowd crowd ignored this person
again even as the cries
came louder they not only ignored him
but some of them made a point to walk
over and shush him those who silenced
the blind beggar named Bartimaeus were
followers of Jesus they were leaving
Jericho with him heading out toward
Jerusalem they were the pious ones the
faithful ones the right ones they were
Jesus followers they were us Bartimaeus
was them Bartimaeus represented all of
the unclean and nuisance people who kept
distracting Jesus many of Jesus
followers therefore told him to be quiet
and walked right on by but then the
blind beggar cried out even more loudly
Jesus son of David have mercy on me if
he could see Bartimaeus would have been
faced with disgusted stairs and stern
looks his sense of eyesight was absent
but his sense of hearing was strong he
could hear the footsteps of the one who
could help him he could hear the voice
of the one who might speak words of hope
his sense of eyesight was absent but his
believing did not depend on his seeing
Jesus have mercy on me in our time of
confession in worship today and most
days we often use this phrase have mercy
on us kiri a la song but what is it we
want Jesus to do when we ask for mercy
spare us from something bring us
something take us somewhere Rolf Jacobs
and writes God's mercy is about
unfairness and that's the good news in
this God's mercy is about unfairness he
writes that if God treated us as
fairness demanded we would be in some
serious trouble if God collected from us
every time we fell behind on our
accounts we would be permanently
spiritually bankrupt if God remembered
it against us every time we worshiped
our idols of money career family war sex
we would be forgotten forever if God
brought charges against us every time we
ignored the widow or orphan we would be
serving multiple eternal life sentences
but God is not fair jacobsen rights God
is merciful God's mercy means that the
door will be unlocked in the lights left
on for us no matter what we've done or
where we've gone we can always go home
to God the one who is graciously unfair
the one who is merciful what does our
Gospel story today tell us about mercy
the mercy Jesus shows to the blind
beggar comes in at least three ways
first of course Jesus restores the sight
of bita Bartimaeus immediately seeing
again would make a relatively normal
life possible for Bartimaeus seeing
again meant that he could navigate those
rough roads or see someone coming up on
him who might be a threat seeing again
meant that he was just poor now not
blind and poor a double way of being
labelled them but the mercy keeps
flowing Jesus extends mercy to this man
even before his eyesight is restored
Jesus shows him mercy by acknowledging
his humanity by really listening to that
persistent cry coming from the roadside
I doubt that happened very often to this
blind beggar it's far easier to cross
over to the other side of the street you
see a blind person coming it's far
easier to study the cracks in the
sidewalk than to answer the call of a
beggar but Jesus acknowledges Bartimaeus
and asks him what would you like me to
do for you and another mercy
in extending mercy to this blind beggar
Jesus erases the line between us and
them he just takes a giant whiteboard
eraser and wipes it away the line
between us and them vanishes when Jesus
hears the cries of Bartimaeus and then
he tells the followers you know the ones
who just shush to our tomatoes to go get
him to call him over to Jesus well
suddenly they are dripping with charity
and they probably put down whatever they
were carrying on the road and they rush
over to greet Bartimaeus like nothing
had just happened that they were the new
best friends huh these hypocrites these
hypocrites and I know the feeling
actually after trusting so much in the
division of us and them when I first
moved to New Haven absence had a big
conversion of heart about this place and
am not scared anymore of its streets of
its people I'm careful yes but I'm happy
to spend my time handing out food on the
green to strangers or making eye contact
with someone asking for money even if I
don't have change in my pocket but I
still think I'm more like those
hypocritical followers because most of
the time this kind of thing makes me
feel really good gives me a nice glow
feel good about myself but it doesn't
quite get more than skin-deep sometimes
it doesn't quite crack open my heart the
way I think Jesus might be asking too I
still trip over the sense of us those
doing the service and them those needing
our help at the end of the day we have
to trust that if food is served and if a
few fewer people have to sleep outside
that some good is being done despite our
motivations our work is not in vain even
if we still struggle with maybe why
we're doing this service is important
God works with our broken motivations we
shouldn't wait until we have totally
solved the US them dilemma in our head
before we offer ourselves to other
people don't beat yourself up if you've
had a hard time approaching people who
are different than you don't get
discouraged if the US and them mentality
has given you some sense of security in
New Haven and you're feeling guilty
about that this Gospel story is not
about condemnation is about the grace of
unfair mercy Jesus does not scold his
followers for being hypocrites that's
mercy they deserve a good scolding
instead he just makes room for
Bartimaeus in his company and keeps on
walking to Jerusalem mercy instead of
healing Bartimaeus but then leaving him
to remain one of the them crowd still a
beggar Bartimaeus is now one of the US
crowd with Jesus traveling to jerusalem
Jesus followers he told him to shut up
now get to walk shoulder to shoulder
with Bartimaeus that's a lesson in mercy
and the blurring of us and them Jesus
asks us to let go of the idea of charity
to them and asks us instead to imagine a
larger us Jesus invites us to share food
and clothing and other important things
but to notice the people most of all
this is one of the reasons that we're
having a conversation after worship
today called who is my neighbor the
question asked to Jesus in the gospel in
our guest Dwayne and Kelly from iris the
integrated refugee and immigrant
services in New Haven are going to talk
with us today about the very real story
of refugees and immigrants in New Haven
the struggles they face coming from Iraq
the Sudan and elsewhere we're collecting
clothing for iris this month but we
wanted to also
to know some of the people working with
iris hear some of the stories it's
harder to pass by the people you know I
just learned about a new book called
they are us especially about Lutheran's
and immigration but it's authors Steve
Bowman and Ralston deffenbaugh paint an
even larger picture of immigration
refugees and the church the book makes
the strong claim that us and them are
false categories and in fact they argue
about immigrants and refugees in
particular they are us I heard Steve
Bowman speak recently and he spent most
of his speech reminding all of us that
we are all descendants of immigrants one
way or another it might be very close
for you you might have parents or
grandparents that speak a native
language other than English or your
immigrant history might have to dust off
be dusted off a little bit more a little
bit further back we remember that the
Israelites our oldest ancestors in the
faith were refugees from Egypt they are
us the authors right we talk about them
as if they are faceless voiceless beings
forgetting perhaps by choice that they
too are children of God they acknowledge
that there is not consensus among
Christians when it comes to immigration
not in the least but nonetheless we are
called to extend mercy to others even as
we debate about laws and policies they
say we may be to be divided on how to
sort out today's immigration mess but
when the stranger knocks at the door
Christians instinctively opened the door
and attend immediately to the needs of
the other the followers of Jesus were
asked to welcome Bartimaeus into their
group traveling out of Jericho
and them the blind beggar and all he
represented became part of the US when
Bartimaeus became part of the US crowd
he did not suddenly become rich and
prosperous I think instead i wonder if
that entire US crowd that group around
Jesus finally realized that they too
were beggars none of them had yet
figured out how to follow Jesus
perfectly instead they were following
him around begging to know more about
him which is why they found themselves
on the road to Jerusalem following Jesus
actually to his death maybe deep in
their souls they were begging Jesus to
ignore the fact that they had just shush
this man who is now walking with them
maybe they were begging to understand
the miracle they had just witnessed when
this blind beggar regained his eyesight
and was invited to join Jesus crowd dt
Niall says it this way Christianity is
one beggar telling another beggar where
he found bread I've never heard it put
more simply Christianity is one beggar
telling another beggar where he found
bread where you find sustenance for your
soul the power of this story in the
Gospel of Mark is the power to remind us
that we are all beggars regardless of
bank account balance where you happen to
live or if you've been securely employed
your whole life we are all somehow
beggars if we are rich it is because God
has shown us rich mercy if we are
prosperous it is because we prosper in
the good news of Christ if we have
abundance it is not really ours but ours
to give away now I know your families
did not send you to Yale to become
beggars but maybe Jesus did maybe Jesus
sent you here
be a beggar maybe this is where we can
practice begging for mercy when we've
messed up maybe this is where we can
practice begging for wisdom beyond just
head knowledge maybe this is where we
can practice begging to understand who
our neighbors are in New Haven instead
of keeping them a safe distance away the
gracious unfairness of God's mercy is
that it is wide so wide extending to all
of us the door is left unlocked the
lights are left on God's mercy extends
to all Jesus told Bartimaeus go your
faith has made you well and so too we
are sent out beggars all with a new
vision with mercy to walk with Christ
thanks be to God amen